try to create a product that is uh
um
like like focus more on on the product
at the beginning we were really customer
centric at the beginning bringing more
and more and more business because we
bootstrapped for three and a half years
so it's a little bit harder to build a
product and then go to market and and we
go to went to market before that so i
think that was
that for for the new entrepreneur i
would say that
you need to draw a little bit more
before you go to market but other than
that just breathe
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to another really really fun
episode of 20 minute leaders today i
have with me omer shirazi the co-founder
and ceo of easy send
omar shirazi 32 years old is the
co-founder and ceo of easy-send a
no-code platform that transforms any
manual process into a digital customer
journey
omer leads easy sends go-to-market teams
globally but still enjoys running a
sales demo on his own every week or two
he is passionate about products data and
integrating innovative software
solutions with business processes and
human teams
omer shirazi welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm really good thank you michael how
are you i'm doing fantastic now that
we're talking here i'm i'm so excited
about you know your own journey and easy
sense journey talking about customer
journeys talking about you know where
you know where we're headed in the
digitalization world but not in 2022
when it's obvious that everything needs
digitalization as we've seen through the
covet pandemic but going back to 2015
when you started easy send and and
helping organizations transform
digitally
especially when it comes to their to
their customers so um tell me you know a
little bit about yourself and you know
who is omer in 2015 when he's the
co-founder of this new startup is
descend
wow and so
honestly i don't even remember i was a
student
third year of uh accounting in economics
in barilan
and i was just
thought that it's time to to get my
first real job you know i
mostly worked in in ball life
until then
and um i started working off uh at
helmando do be amazing place amazing
people this is where i met tal uh with
the ceo of the company at the moment and
with one of the co-founders obviously
with me and iran
and he's leading us to uh
throughout those this year in those
years and i think i was uh working
part-time even three times a week and al
was
teaching me the job and still
studying obviously and i remember us and
talking about new
new things that you maybe want to do a
lot of issues with the service and a lot
of things that or
involving manual forms and new
initiatives that
we want to want to do and we thought
about numerous
numerous things i remember us talking
about and something that is related to
um social media and other things that
were related to um
more to accounting and an economy
overall and we
thought that
it was a really good opportunity to
start where with customer service uh
where we were part of it and we knew all
about it so we decided to take it one
step forward and i remember us not even
thinking about anything
other than what happened six months from
now when i'm starting my internship and
then and tal is is gonna have a few
other businesses as he was a huge
entrepreneur so we didn't think anything
more than six months forward
incredible so
i wasn't even aware of this you actually
started easy send you know six months
before you were about to start an
internship and six years later you're
now the chief operating officer
previously chief product officer of a
company that raised more than 70 million
dollars and has over 120 people at least
according to linkedin
unbelievable huh
how
your personal journey omer shirazi what
is going on in your world as you're
progressing both in leadership and
professionalism how do you know
reflecting back what was this whole
experience like for you
so it's a huge challenge like
every day
day in day out you're coming into the
office and thinking if we are doing the
right thing and and how can you do
better and it is even going the right
way and which way we need to go and it's
something that obviously i couldn't do
without
our
um
my funding team but with any of the
employees of physicists and like all of
them are amazing and all of them are are
part of this uh journey with me and
i think my overall uh
journey will change significantly every
year basically i'm doing sales for three
and a half years now in eastern at the
beginning i was the first really the
first salesman with tal and
we were
going knocking door to door and and
closing
new customers one by one and then um i
started the
um leading the sales team and recording
salesmans in israel and then recording
salesman's in um
usa in europe and uh in
now in australia even and then bringing
in the first customer in united states
in europe and in other countries as well
now we have
customers in seven countries and it was
just changing from every year
because um you you started off by doing
sales by yourself and then
coaching and training the first person
and then coaching and training the first
team leaders and now i have three vps
under my supervision that are managing
the whole globe so it's just getting
from one place to another but i must say
every time it's another challenge it's
something that
um is always uh um
you need to react really fast to to the
to the things that are changing and
think on your feet
what what skills did you have to develop
personally as you're transitioning from
you know being the salesperson who's
actually doing the sale and you know
you're doing the you know what what are
we saying in hebrew
and then you know over time you're
shifting to
supervising these processes up to the
point where now your lead you're
supervising three vice presidents each
of
which has their own division right so
what skill sets do you have to develop
in order to be able to think more
strategically at a higher level and sort
of guide this organization
so my personal background as i said is i
even started as a programmer when i was
really little and
my personal um
um is like accounting in
an economy so i didn't have much of a
selling skills and so this is something
that i obviously needed to work on by
myself but i have guidance and from
three years already in the making i
always have some sort of a third party
guidance that
helps me through it and
in any of those points i got
the right guidance so at the beginning
to just become a salesman i think me and
tal are natural and we just did it
together day in day out and we taught
each other and afterwards bringing in
the first sales team and building the
first funnel we didn't even know how
funnel works and i think we learned it
together
and after that i started using third
party
consultants that really helped me so
um i already i can remember at least
four of them that were helping me
throughout the
the career and helped me learn basically
everything that needed to be learned and
then learning from videos learning from
articles but overall a lot of hours
spent with uh with with help and they
guide me through it and i i guess that
you always need for me you always need
to be to have somebody that already did
or
been in your path that can help you
guide you through it because it's
it's so challenging anyway so at least
somebody can tell you that he knows the
what happens when and what you should be
done and this is something that i i
really believe in
i love it take me back to the first six
months
of easy send you're not even sure that
you're you know that what you're gonna
be doing six months later you might have
an internship lined up
what is happening in these six months
that
sort of consolidates you as a as a
company as a real startup that is
running ahead
um
i'm going to say really like what we're
doing really like walking one with
another and i think for the first six
months i we walked for my
my bedroom in my parents apartment like
it was that small and
i remember us talking about it
every time that we had but it was
again our second job we we did something
else and
i was a student working and and always
student
and working and and when we're walking
in our place so i remember that we took
all our spare time weekends and every
everything that we couldn't put into it
and so it was very hard to keep a
balance but i remember us always
thinking to ourselves is it real is it
we are actually
getting another customer another cut
system and another customer i remember
us thinking of other competitors that
were in the market at that time and they
were huge they had like 14 15 16
employees and had numerous customers we
thought to ourselves how we can compete
with them and obviously now they will
turn a little bit
as you're growing the organization take
me through the
professional understanding of easy send
from a market perspective what what is
the pain point that as the easy scent is
pushing forward what is the big pain
point that you're solving and then i'd
love to hear a little bit about you know
the big milestones of the company that
really validated your solution to this
pain point
cool so our elevator pitch is pretty
simple is taking manual forms and
converting them into a beautifully
designed intelligent digital process
using non-code builder everything can be
done with no programming knowledge
basically and this is what we're doing
with
numerous customers around the globe so i
think for me um
there was the first customer that
started the
working with our forms and implementing
them or embedding them in their in their
website then there was customers that
starting working with our builder and
starting building by themselves and
those forms and after that doing
everything again in europe and doing
everything again in the united states
and suddenly seeing that it's all
works in the same way and in this way i
feel that um
we can actually
start seeing a really good product
market feed where
most of the insurance sector which is
our main sector is acting the same
around the globe and we can start
finding out the same use cases or the
same pain points that they're all
experiencing and in the same time and
try to
um hopefully create a product that fits
to all so i guess that's
once you do it the same thing with
insurance now going
the second step will be doing it with
other sectors and opening new sectors so
we're already working with numerous
banks and like we have i think
six or seven banks around the globe and
then we're now trying to open loaners
and automotive companies and and it's
getting there probably health and
government after that
if we're looking at your your onboarding
of the first customers you know you're
talking both about the insurance space
so highly regulated you know very exact
a i had a little bit of experience in
the insure in the interior tech space
myself so i understand the complexity of
of what it means to manage information
in the insurance space but at the same
time you're dealing with teams that are
non-technical because the promise is
that they don't have to spend time on
the technology
what is that process like onboarding
them explaining the possibilities
getting their trust
to both for the pii or the personal
information to flow through you but also
just for them to trust the defensibility
of your platform because at the end
their business is working you know in a
certain way for a long time and you're
coming in and shifting even a small part
of it it's a critical piece
i agree um i must say it's much easier
than it sounds
our customers are amazing they have
amazing people working for them and they
are technical teams and they have their
own business teams and insurance and and
banking is so complicated like it
sometimes we hear complaints about how
insurance and banking sectors operates i
must it's operates much better than it
should be it's so complicated right it's
like um
so many things that you need to know in
regulation and they are doing really
really good job and i think for us
immediately when we start talking about
in with a new customer we understand
each other pretty well we understand the
insurance sector they
know what what they are looking for and
i think it clicks pretty well this is
why our onboarding is not such a
[Music]
drag it takes pretty much 30-45 days and
um
i guess this is something that works
really well for us
right now the the product market fed
journey i'm guessing that wasn't an
overnight thing where you know you've
got i'm not getting there even
not there yet
how how do you think through product
market fit six years later and the
journey towards product market fit
so i i think this is something that you
figure it depends what are you what kind
of product are you selling i think
eastern is pretty unique because it's a
new product that
even
companies like gartner doesn't really
have a spectrum on it and no code is um
for me is something very robust but
there is so many
local no code solution that doing many
different things so it's very hard to
place us so in this way i think that um
it starts with the first clients and
then understanding for them what they
really need and then sharpening your
product more and then bringing other
clients and shopping the product more
until it's um its feeds
and i think that
every year that passed it's making our
lives
in the sales team much easier and very
easy
to approach new customers and new
sectors so i think this is something
that is um a journey that takes time but
it it's something that our customers
helped us carve out
right i think that i think that really
makes a lot of sense and you know the
world obviously is
everybody's
was brought up to the or caught up to
the idea that nobody everything has to
be digital everything has to be
electronic and and the experience seems
to be seamless especially for the
customers so if you're looking to date
easy setting the early 2022 and
transitioning into the upcoming years
where how are you thinking strategically
now versus how you were until now sort
of where where are we headed
somewhere big
and successful
um
i think that
according to what we are looking for i
think that we're going to have
um we're going to triple our customers a
amount in this year probably and the
year after and i hopefully we will
become a huge
company that leading this market around
the globe isn't that the definition of
product market fit
yeah yeah this is what i'm saying this
this year this is where we're getting i
i believe that this is something that we
achieved last year and now we we're
gonna
um pick all the low ending fruits and
and we're doing it year after year we're
usually tripling our customer amounts
every year so if everything goes
correctly and
as tal says we're going to win
and and what keeps you up at night as
the chief operating officer with three
vice presidents under your supervision
six years after almost taking that
internship at another company what is
keeping america at night up right now
well my my new my
newborn she's six months old her name is
danielle
she's amazing and she has some trouble
sleeping full nights so it's a little
bit her
and most of you are losing her i would
say
mostly her and and from the small
moments where you are thinking about
easy sand or you're thinking about you
know something that happened throughout
the day
what do you find lingers is it more the
easy scent as a as a business as a
product or is it more leadership things
that are happening that that are new to
you and you're not sure how to tackle
yet
look there's
a lot of challenges and if you go into
them you you easily can lose some sleep
but we have amazing team and i'm i know
that we're going to prevail and i know
that
um
founding team management team to the
mid-level the managers to to every
employee in the company
we're going to work together until we we
succeed and then we we build a this is
an empire from from whatever we need to
where we where is needed
omar i don't think i've yet to have
somebody on the show that is so
optimistic and happy as you are yeah
i love it no no i think i think it's a
really good thing
so so looking back and i and this is a
very unique perspective because it's
it's not that frequent that i'm meeting
somebody who's now you know
one of the leaders of such a cool
company but just a few years ago they
were in the big sort of the beginning of
their journey and going into an
internship
if you were to look back what would you
tell omer six years ago and obviously
this is a question for any young
entrepreneur just starting their journey
you know fresh and
what kind of things are non-trivial that
we should be keeping in mind
um
that's a good question um i would say
that
um try to create a product that is uh
um like like focus more on on the
product at the beginning we were really
customer centric at the beginning
bringing more and more and more business
because we bootstrapped for three and a
half years so it's a little bit harder
to build the product and then go to
market be and and we go to went to
market before that so i think that was
uh that for for the new entrepreneur i
would say that
you need to draw a little bit more
before you go to market but other than
that just breathe
it's a it's a roller coaster and uh
you need to to go into it
what is the part that you enjoy most out
of everything
um
i think that i really like the the
persons that i'm working with i really
like myself evolving into this new new
um
very dynamic position and going into it
and every year there is a really big new
challenge i think this is a very dynamic
workspace workplace and i like it i
don't know if i can do any different
so omel before i let you go back to
running helping run your company
and it can't be trivial co-founding a
company with your brother as one of the
co-founders
six years in the making you know what
what is that like you know just working
day in and day out with your brother
i think this is
first of all i must say it's not uh it's
not very different than walking with
with tal like
we are actually
for six and a half years with our wives
and and just together
so it's it's very very alike but with
the run is going into friday nights and
and saturday mornings i think somehow we
we found a really good way to separate
the two
and were really good friends in the same
way but
totally something that we can
teach others how to do you need to you
need to make sure that you're saying
everything the correct way and know how
to walk even when on bad times and
and i think we're doing it amazingly
i'm glad to have those partners
i really really want to thank you
this is awesome best of luck with your
journey
i coming into this i just wanted to
congratulate and hear what was happening
until now but you're already living in
the future and you're thinking about the
next few years and tripling your
customers and becoming a market leader
which is just awesome and so i'm so glad
that i caught you in this inflection
point it sounds like for easy send where
so much hard work has been put in so
much more is left to come but but still
an incredible journey so so tada ba and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
[Music]